avez-vous des rancune envers la
production bas voilà ça tombe bien un
écran large ou r oui ah ouais bon alexia
laroche joubert
j'ai plein d'arguments je confirme à la
faillite est très sympa mais je suis
restée en dedans alors c'est quelqu'un
qui n'a pas été correct avec touré et
pur produit pour elle thaler elle est
venue se pavaner dans les loges
jean pascal a été bien reçue dans les
loges c'est à dire que moi je les fais
bien comprendre que ce que je pensais de
m et je pense que j'étais pas le seul
alexia laroche joubert s'est elle se
pavane sur la maison on était délégué du
grand duel est à l est et d une halte à
dire les couleurs aux manettes on a
réjoui les louper aucun respect pour
elle a eu aucun respect pour nous thaler
à l'aide du spam année elle la première
n a pas dû se sentir très à l'aise et
c'est très bien je reste je peux me
permettre
en fait à l'époque on avait tous
traversé des moments aussi
psychologiques assez compliqué après le
loft et moi je me rappelle qu'un jour ma
mère m'a raconté une anecdote qui l'a
beaucoup marqué l a appelée alexia
laroche-joubert un jour à lui ai dit
vous savez ma fille elle se sent pas
bien là besoin d'un suivi psychologique
parce que c'est vrai que là la
difficulté qu'on a eue après c'est qu'on
était quand même fragilisé plus ou moins
par cette expérience
et est ce qu'on a reproché à la preuve
c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de suivi après
ce qui n'était pas le cas après des
émissions qui ont suivi après parce que
le je crois que le parcours
psychologique il a été installé
instaurer un village m2 ya jamais eu un
suivi de ouf non à diouf mais la
production s'est soucié un peu plus des
candidats que nous à notre époque
un jour ma mère appelle alexia laroche
joubert et à l'excellent the bar un lieu
d'écouté vous n'allez pas nous faire
chier votre fille a gagné assez d'argent
avec l'offre donc ça sert à rien que
voilà donc y'a un moment donné il ya le
revers aussi de dollars je veux dire ya
les coulisses et yahia ce qu'on montre à
la télévision
japan a eu un accompagnement qui n'a pas
été à la hauteur de ce qu'on avait de ce
qu'on avait besoin à l'époque je pense
qu on était jeunes on a été je pense là
c'est aussi fragilisée même si ça a été
une très belle expérience non l'été
charles on n'était pas préparé à ça et
je crois quand même nos familles on sous
les regards des saints alex et ses deux
copines mais je pense aussi que en son
temps un peu comme vous il a été dépassé
par le truc parce qu'elle était tout
jeune est aussi elle avait cinq ou six
ans de plus que vous et je pense que je
pense que en fait personne et on peut le
dire ce soir
quand on a vécu cette aventure au moment
où elle a vécu et même un peu après on
n'a personne n'a pris la mesure
ouais mais là elle dit
whissell a remis deux jours je pense
qu'elle a manqué un peu d'humanité d2 et
de sympathie vis-à-vis de nous je pense
qu'après ça a été justement voilà
puisqu'on parle d'humanité qui me fait
rien on va s'arrêter
mais les gentils bourrique ça dépend
peut-être mémoire en ce qui me concerne
mais bien sûr mais voilà je pense qu'il
n'y a rien à lui reprocher chacun a vécu
et son expérience